debout les vieux le moment est venu de
parler de dire d'où nous venons comment
voulez vous qu'on ne reproche pas à des
jeunes adolescents de croire que la vie
commence avec eux si nous les vieux nous
ne leur avons jamais raconter d'où nous
venons il faut donc absolument que ces
générations qui se succèdent se parlent
s'écoutent se rencontrent se transmettre
sans cela évidemment nous allons à une
catastrophe de guerre des générations de
sacrifice des hommes d autre qu était
d'ailleurs un hic motif assez assez
effrayant est récurrent depuis très
longtemps on se demande si la génération
qui est qu'il y avait 20 en 1914
évidemment elle a été la génération
sacrifiée mais celles qui avaient 20 ans
elle a été la génération sacrifiée celle
qui a fait la guerre d'algérie
génération sacrifiée
en 1999 il ya un rappeur français qui
s'appelle rohff qui a exactement qui
donne ce titre à une de ses chansons un
de ses textes que franchement moi je
n'apprécie pas spécialement
n'empêche que me voilà donc il y a tout
le temps pour une génération la
possibilité
la question que tout de se dire et si
nous étions la génération sacrifiée
mais si les jeunes si la génération qui
a 20 ans regarde ceux qui en ont 70 en
se disant eux c'est boomer ils ont eu
tout et nous nous n'avons rien nous
n'aurons rien évidemment ils se trompent
non les vieux n'ont pas tous eu les
générations de 68 il a fallu qu'elle
emmène des combats des luttes pour
obtenir des choses et bien le monde
s'ouvre devant cette génération qui a 20
ans ce monde je les fais pour toi disait
le père rose c'est une maladie déjà 10 l
enfant ou souvenez de maxime le
forestier
oui bah voilà oui il y à un chantier
gigantesque à ouvrir ouvrons le ensemble
pour que les vieux et les jeunes
bâtissent ensemble cette société qu'il
nous faut ré avons
[Musique]